once a normal looking guy Eric Sprague
has gone to great lengths to radically
transform his body he's the lizard man
and outcasts by design I would like to
introduce the little green man the freak
of nature the lizard man these days Eric
works as a sideshow performer today he's
on stage at a tattoo convention outside
Syracuse New York
it's a sympathetic crowd but Eric knows
that the rest of the world isn't so
accepting of what was done to his body
by radically marking the visible parts
of his body with pointed teeth green
scaly skin and Teflon implants under his
eyebrows Eric sends a message that he no
longer wants to play by society's rules
for those at the tattoo show Eric's
message is clear he's willing to go to
greater lengths than most to set himself
apart for many in this modified crowd
since something of ethereal body piercer
Danny Van Buren has decided to follow
Eric's lead and take his markings public
okay brother Danny will be pricked with
a needle for almost three hours it's a
painful process ultimately Danny wants
his entire body covered with ink he
wants to be just like Eric you'll never
get to see it from this perspective but
it looks good when it's finally over
danny is happy to have joined Eric's
ranks three hours there's no turning
back now so I'm just gonna keep going
and going and going for the members of
his modification community
Eric continues to be a trailblazer
before heading back to Austin he's
getting another tattoo in a very
sensitive place this time his lips will
be turned from pink to green the first
day I
requiring Erik's still hoping to have
almost 300 more hours of work done on
his body before his transformation is
complete choosing to live life as a
lizard man 24/7 isn't for most people
but for Eric and others willing to cross
the line becoming an outcast is price
they're willing to pay for being true to
how they see themselves no matter what
that makes them in the eyes of others